hey everyone my name is marcin iwinski
and i'm the co-founder of cedar project
when i started celebrate 25 years ago
one of its founding principles was
honest and direct communication with
gamers
once at the break read the game
development part of celebrate was born
it added something important to that
principle the ambition to make the best
games in the world
it became our mission and something that
guided us up until now
based on that legacy of genuine and
honest communication you've
trusted us and pre-ordered our game and
despite good reviews on pc
the console version of cyberpunk 2077
did not meet the quality standard
we wanted it to meet i and the entire
leadership team are deeply sorry for
this
and this video is me publicly owning up
to that
please don't fault any of our teams for
what happened
they all are incredibly talented and
hardworking
myself and the board are the final
decision makers and it was our call to
release the game
although believe me we never ever
intended for anything like this to
happen
i assure you that we'll do our best to
regain your trust
now i'd like to tell you how the
situation looked like from the inside
cyberpunk 2077
is huge in scope and i'm not only
talking about quests or things you see
at first glance
i'm talking about a multitude of custom
objects interacting systems and
mechanics
in the game everything is not stretched
out over flat terrain where we can make
things less taxing hardware wise
but condensed in one big city and in a
relatively loading free environment
on its own this is a challenge but we
made it even more difficult for
ourselves
by wanting to make the game look epic on
pcs and then adjusting it to consoles
especially old gems
that was our core assumption and things
did not look super difficult at first
we knew the hardware gap yes but
ultimately
i think that time has proven that we've
underestimated the task
to give a concrete example and the main
culprit we had to constantly improve our
in-game streaming system for all gen
consoles
streaming is responsible for feeding the
engine with what you see on screen
as well as the game mechanics and since
the city is so packed and the disk
bandwidth of audience
is what it is it constantly challenged
us
every change and improvement needed to
be tested and as it turned out our
testing did not show a big part of the
issues you experienced while playing the
game
as we got closer to the final release we
saw significant improvements each and
every day
and we really believed we would deliver
in the final day zero update
now let's talk about the review process
we started sending our pc review keys in
the first days of december
on launch day december 10th we hit the
ground running with a really good start
on pc
while not perfect it's a version of
cyberpunk we are very proud of
at the same time we're fighting for
quality on all gen consoles till the
very last
moment and every extra day of us working
on the day zero
update brought visible improvement this
is where we started sending console
review keys on the 8th of december
which was later than we originally
planned this all happened
while working from home with all the
challenges resulting from the covet
related restrictions
a lot of the dynamics we normally take
for granted got lost over video calls or
email
and we took that hit too now i'd like to
tell you about our plans for the future
and present a path for cyberpunk 2077 on
consoles and pc we have already released
three hotfixes improving the game but
that's just the beginning
our ultimate goal is to fix the bugs and
crashes gamers are experiencing across
platforms
please expect bigger and smaller patches
on a regular basis
the first update will be dropping within
10 days and it will be followed by
another
more significant one in the following
weeks we will of course continue to work
on the game in future updates and
improvements beyond that
our big plans for supporting cyberpunk
in the long term
did not change as for the free dlcs
our initial plan was to deliver them
just after the release
much like we did with the witcher 3. we
decided to focus on the most important
fixes and updates first and will be
releasing the dlcs
afterwards expect more information in
the upcoming months
for those of you playing on next-gen
consoles in back compatibility
you can still expect the free next-gen
update for xbox series consoles
and playstation 5 arriving in 2021 we
are aiming at the second half of the
year
i'd like to end this video by assuring
you that we treat this entire situation
very seriously and are working hard to
make it right
the guiding principles of our company
are still core to what we do
we still want to make amazing games and
have an open communication with you our
players
for now our immediate focus is to work
hard on making sure you enjoy cyberpunk
2077 regardless of platform
beyond cyberpunk we have many plans for
the future
which we'll share more about when we're
ready thank you for taking the time to
watch this video
you